FIRST BILL HEARING OF TWENTY
NINETEEN FOR THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES.
WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY WE WILL ALSO BE VOTING TO
ADOPT COMMITTEE RULES FOR THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
SO WE'LL GO AHEAD.
SO SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
CA.GOV.
HER TENURE HERE STONE.
STONE HERE BELL.
BELL HERE JACKSON JACKSON HERE
PAN.
PAN HERE WIENER.
PRESENT.
WINNER HERE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
UP NOW IT'S TIME TO A DOCTOR
COMMITTEE RULES FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
AB SECTOR PLEASE COUPLE.
ARE TIED UP HERE HER TITLE I
DON'T.
STONE AYE BELL.
BELL AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN.
PAN AYE WIENER.
AYE WIENER AYE.
OKAY WILL WILL GO HEAD IN HERE --
US SENATOR DODD TO PRESENT SB
ONE SEVEN THREE WELCOME TO
SENATOR DOTTING YOUR WITNESSES --
YES THE WHIMS OF KEEP THEIR
TESTIMONY TWO TO THREE MINUTES
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY.
IT'S GREAT TO BE BACK.
O. K. WELL THANK YOU I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY AGREEING TO
TAKE THE CAR FINDING A COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS BEING OFFERED.
IN THE ANALYSIS.
I SB TEN SEVENTY THREE IS
INTENDED TO INCREASE AWARENESS
AND UTILIZATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
BY STUDENTS.
PARTICIPATING A WORK STUDY
THROUGH A UNIFORM L. G. B.
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION
PROCESS.
IN ORDER FOR A COLLEGE STUDENT
ENROLLED AT LEAST HALF TIME TO
APPLY FOR CAL FRESH FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRES THEY MEET CRTAIN
EXEMPTIONS ONE QUALIFYING
CRITERIA BEING.
PARTICIPATION IN WORK STUDY.
CURRENTLY MANY COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSI UTILIZE DIFFERENT FORMS
FOR THE SAME STUDIO ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION PURPOSE WHICH
MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
COUNTY STAFF WHO PROCESS CAL
FLAT CALIBRATION.
APPLICATIONS TO KNOW
CONCLUSIVELY WHICH STUDENTS MAY
QUALIFY FOR ANY ELIGIBILITY
EXEMPTION SB TEN SEVENTY THREE
WILL REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY.
WITH OUR PUBLIC COLLEGES TO
CREATE STANDARD A STANDARD FORM
THAT STUDENTS CAN TAKE TO THE
CALLIE ELIGIBILITY WORKERS
STANDARDIZE IN THIS PROCESS
ACROSS COUNTIES.
I HAVE TWO WITNESSES WITH ME
TODAY NO AND AND SERVICES.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
ALEX.
ALEX FROM --
REPRESENTING --
YOLO COUNTY.
HELLO MY NAME IS NOLAN SULLIVAN
I'M A BRANCH DIRECTOR FOR YOU'LL
COUNTY HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES --
I OVERSEE THE COUNTIES CAL FIRST
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY --
YOLO COUNTY SURPRISINGLY HAS THE
LARGEST STUDENT OVERALL
EIGHT COUNTIES WE HAVE MORE
STUDENTS AND YOLO.
THAN MOST OTHER COUNTIES SO
WE'RE VERY VERY FOCUSED ON UC
DAVIS IN PARTICULAR --
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH
STUDENTS APPLYING FOR CALIFORNIA
SHOES THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY MEET.
AN EXEMPTION SO IF THEY DON'T
MEET EXEMPTION THEY CAN'T EVEN
APPLY. ONE OF THE MORE COMMON
EXEMPTIONS IS WORK STUDY SO --
THE REASON WE'RE HERE TODAY IS --
TO ASKED TO PUT THIS BILL
FORWARD --
TO PUT THINGS IN PERSPECTIVE
COLLEGE STUDENTS. FIFTEEN
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY COULD BE WORK STUDY
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS --
OF THOSE --
FIFTEEN THREE THIRTY TWELVE
HUNDRED OR SO ACTUALLY RECEIVE
WORK STUDY SO THERE'S A HUGE
POOL OF POSSIBILITY ELIGIBLE COW
FRESH.
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS THE PROBLEM
IS THE STUDENTS OFTENTIMES GET
DIFFERENT FORMS DIFFERENT
NOTICES DIFFERENT EMAILS --
OR DIFFERENT ALERTS FROM THE
VARIOUS CAMPUSES IN THE DON'T
KNOW THEY COULD POTENTIALLY BE
ELIGIBLE CAL FRESH SO BY PUSHING
THIS BILL FORWARD.
OR EMPOWERING STUDENTS TO BE
NOTIFIED OF THEIR POSSIBLE
WORLDS BOUTIQUE FOR CALIFORNIA --
AND HELPING GET MORE FOOD ON
CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES.
THANK YOU ALEX TANGO X. WITH THE
CHARACTERS OFFICE IN YOLO COUNTY
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE LA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
THIS BILL IS A PRIORITY FOR US
WE APPRECIATE CENTER DODD AND
OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
AS KNOWN ARTICULATED --
NGUY CAMPUSES.
OF IMPORTANT ISSUE STATEWIDE
PARTICULAR SO AND YOLO COUNTY
AND WE THINK THIS WOULD BE A
SIMPLE TOOL TO STERILIZE PROCESS
STREAMLINED IT BOTH FOR
UNIVERSITIES AND FOR COUNTY --
WHAT ARE WELFARE ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS --
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DRIVE OUT.
OKAY IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL -- IF
SO PLEASE COME TO THE STANDING
MICROPHONE AND STATE YOUR NAME A
WHAT ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT
OF ANY AND YOUR POSITION OF
SUPPORT.
CARLY SINGLE WITH THE FOOD BANK
OF CONTRA COSTA AND SOLANO IN
STRONG SUPPORT WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF HEALTH FRESH OUT REACH
WORKERS WHO GO TO CAMPUS IS TO
TRY AND HELP STUDENTS APPLY FOR
CALL FRESH.
AND THE ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
FOR STUDENTS TO PARTICULAR VERY
COMPLICATED AND ANYTHING THAT
COUNTY CAN DO TO STREAMLINE THAT
PROCESS AND PROACTIVELY REACH
OUT TO STUDENTS WILL BE A GREAT
BENEFIT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY'S UNDERLING WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WERE IN SUPPORT.
REVENUE EVERYBODY PARTIAL
HISTORY WITH THE UC SAN
ASSOCIATION WHEN SUPPORT.
HI DOES BARTOLO WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN AS THE
COLDEST CALIFORNIA FOR RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JUSTIN SO MIKE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WE DO NOT
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION AT THIS
TIME WE ARE RECOMMENDING A
SUPPORT TO OUR BOARD OF
GOVERNORS AT THEIR NEXT MEETING.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
IF SO PEASE COME TO THE
STANDING MIKE AND SIMPLY STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION.
AND YOUR POSITION IN OPPOSITION.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THIS COMITTEE FOR
SENATOR DODD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR DOT --
FOR BRING BRING UP THIS AND
PROVIDES WHAT THE CLARIFY AND
ASSEMBLY --
THAT -- IN
TERMS OF THE BENEFIT THE
STANDARDIZED FORM.
BUT I WAS JUST COULD FIND FOR
THE WITNESSES WHO TESTIFIED FOR
IS THE MAIN ISSUE THE CHALLENGE
FOR THE ELIGIBILITY STAFF TO DO
IS IT ABOUT WHERE IN THIS OF
STUDENTS THAT THEY MAY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR A CAL FRESH AYE.
AYE IT SEEM LIKE YOU'RE PLAY IS
I I JUST CLARIFY OR MAYBE IT'S
BOTH BUT I JUST TRY --
SO CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE BILL
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT HAT
FOR BY -- I
ALSO TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHERE OUR
RATE LIMITING STATUS WHAT WHICH
WHICH PART IS THE ISSUES THAT
THAT MAINLY THE AWARENESS ARTS
ALSO THE ELIGIBILITY SIDE FOR
THE COUNTY TRYING TO FIGUREOUT
THIS PERSON QUALIFY.
A GREAT QUESTION I I WOULD SAY
IT'S BOTH FOR THE STUDENT AND
THE ELIGIBILITY WORKER AND SO.
THE CALPERS PROGAM IS BASED ON
USDA REGULATIONS OF THE STATE
HAS TO INTERPRET THAT REGULATION
AND THEN IN TURN PASS THAT
INTERPRETATION DOWN TO FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY SO.
THERE'S OFTENTIMES MA'AM BEAUTY
THERE THEN YOU FACTOR IN
HUNDREDS OF OF COLLEGES THAT ALL
HAVE A DIFFERENT FINANCIAL AID
OFFICE WITH A DIFFERENT FORM A
DIFFERENT DOCUMENT.
AND THEN YOU HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS.
WHO HAVE TO GET THAT FORMER
DOCUMENT WHICHEVER ONE THAT IS
THE FINANCIAL AID OFFICE USES
BRING THAT TO THEIR CAL FRESH
WORKER FROM THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES?
THERE'S JUST AND AN UNBELIEVABLE
AMOUNT OF AMBIGUITY THERE AND SO
IDEALLY WHAT THIS WILL HELP IS
THE STUDENT WILL SAY HEY STUDENT
GO GET FORM.
AB BUT WHATEVER AND THEN THE
STUDENT WAS EXACTLY WHAT THEY
NEED TO GET AND THEN FOR THE
ELIGIBILITY WORKER WHICH THERE'S
THOUSANDS OF IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S REALLY CLEAR THEM TO THAT
YOU NEED FORM ACTS VERSUS --
A MILLION DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
WE GET OKAY SEES YOU SEE THAT
DEBORAH PROBABLY THAT THE
FINANCIAL AID OFFICE OF PROVIDE
THE FORMS ARE SOME COULD NOT
OFFICE WITH RIDE THE FORM WHICH
THEN THE STUDENT COULD USE TO
TAKE THAT I WOULD REALLY WORKERS
WHO CAN.
YES SIR EXACTLY THAT THAT'S OUT
OF THE AIR NAY OKAY YEAH EXACTLY
FANTASTIC OKAY WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BUILT APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU INSERTS.
THIS HEARTENING THAT WE HAVE TO
BE HAVING THIS CONVERSATION THAT
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE GOING TO SCHOOL.
ARE SO FOOD AND SECURE --
BUT THAT BEING SAID --
I'M WONDERING I ABOUT THE CAL
FRESH PROGRAM VERSUS FOOD BANKS
THAT I KNOW ARE --
SHOWING UP IN SPROUTING UP ON
VARIOUS CAMPUSES TODAY --
THE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM IS
SPECIFICALLY DIRECTED AT
STUDENTS WHO WERE ON FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAMS IS THAT CORRECT.
NOT NOT IN PARTICULAR SO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BE IN FINANCIALLY
TO BE ON CAL FOR ACTUALLY YOU
HAVE TO MEET AN EXEMPTION ON
THERE'S ABOUT TWELVE DIFFERENT
EXEMPTIONS FOR A COLLEGE STUDENT
TO APPLY.
SOME OF THE MORE COMMON
EXEMPTIONS WOULD BE --
YOU'RE WORKING OVER TWENTY HOURS
A WEEK WHICH IS KIND OF UNUSUAL
FOR A LOT OF STUDENTS --
WORK STUDY COULD BE ONE CAL YOU
HAVE A CHILD WHICH IS ANOTHER
COMMON ONE THERE'S A COUPLE
SMALL OFFBEAT.
MORE LIKELY THAN NOT YOU'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO BE ON
FINANCIALLY TO SOME SHAPE OR
FORM BUT IT'S NOT OF COLLUSION
OR A A GATE KEEPING FACTORS CHOI
ASSET BECAUSE I WONDER WHETHER.
THIS --
WHETHER IT'S CONSISTENT OR NOT
WITH THE INTENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION TO ALSO --
MAKE THIS INFORMATION AVAILABLE
TO ALL STUDENTS --
THAT THERE ARE FOOD BANKS AT
THESE DIFFERENT SCHOOL THAT AT A
NUMBER OF SCHOOLS.
THAT MAY NOT.
REQUIRE THE THE THE CAL FOR A
SHOULD YOU KNOW THE FAIRLY
EXTENSIVE.
THE CRITERIA THAT EXISTS TO TO
QUALIFY UNDER CAL FRESH --
IS THERE ANY REASON THAT YOU
CAN'T HAVE SORT OF ONE OUT REACH
ONE PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS STUDENTS
WHETHER THEY ARE.
GOOD THEY QUALIFY FOR CAL
FRAZIER MY QUALIFY FOR FOOD
BANKS. TO TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THAT FOOD IS THAT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WE WANT STUDENTS
TO BE ABLE TO EAT.
AND TO BE ABLE TO EAT HOPEFULLY
IN A HEALTHY WAY WELL THEIR
STUDENTS LEARNING.
YOU KNOW THE THE TASKS THAT ARE
GOING TO MAKE THEIR MARK
ECONOMIC BASE IN THE FUTURE --
COULD YOU RESPOND TO THAT --
I THINK ACTUALLY IN THE BILL
ANALYSIS TO THERE IS A SECTION
IT CITES FOODS FOOD BANKS ON
CAMPUS AS WELL WHICH IS A SAD
FACT AS YOU POINTED OUT WE HAVE
TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION --
CAL FRESH ALSO HAS SOME
LIMITATIONS IN TERMS OF WHO CAN
APPLY SO I I DO CERTAINLY AGREE
HUNGER ON CAMPUS IS A HUGE
PROBLEM IT'S IT'S IT'S AN
EPIDEMIC ACROSS THE U. S. --
THERE WAS SOME WORK DONE LAST
YEAR SOME REALLY ASSEMBLY BILL --
TWENTY FOUR TO FOURTEEN THAT
ACTUALLY DID A VERY SIMILAR
THING WITH CAL GRANT AND HAD
DIFFERENT CAMPUSES NOTIFY --
STUDENTS IF THEY'RE ON CAL GRANT
AS AN EXEMPTION AND SO AS PART
OF THIS AS WELL AND IT'S PART OF
THE THE BILL TO CENTER DOT IS
PROPOSING.
OUR TALKING BUT BRING THIS TO A
WORKER FOR COMMUNITY TALK ABOUT
THESE ISSUES AND I THINK IT'S
GONNA TAKE MORE THAN ONE THING
TO SOLVE THE WHOLE PROBLEM --
SNAP IS THE FEDERAL TERM FOR FOR
CAL FRESH IT'S A SUPPLEMENT
NUTRITION ASSISTANCE PROGRAM SO
CAL FRESH IS BY NO MEANS MEANT
TO USE FOR FILL ALL OF YOUR FOOD
NEED THAT THE SUPPLEMENTAL.
PIECE SO I THINK THE MORE THAT
WE CAN DO TO KIND OF WE'VE ALL
THOSE WEBS AND PULL ALL THOSE
PIECES TOGETHER --
THE THE MORE WE CAN COMBAT THIS
ISSUE ON CAMPUSES AND THAT SORT
OF MY BOTTOM LINE IS THERE SOME
WAY WE CAN.
DO THAT WE CAN INCORPORATE THEM
SO THAT STUDENTS DON'T HAVE TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT THERE WHICH
ONE OF SIXTEEN PROGRAMS THEY MAY
QUALIFY FOR IN THAT.
THEY CAN JUST GO TO ONE PLACE
FIND OUT WHERE THEY CAN GET THAT
FOOD THEY NEED AND BE ABLE --
TO ACCESS.
EXCEPT FOR WHETHER STUDENTS IS
THAT.
BECAUSE OF ALL THE DIFFERENT.
LEVELS OF BUREAUCRACY.
UNREALISTIC CHORUSES SOMETHING
YOU'RE WORKING TOWARDS.
I THINK IT'S A GREAT SUGGESTION
I THINK OF THAT CAME FROM FROM
SOMEBODY THAT.
IT'S COUNTIES AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY ERA YOU
SEASONS YES YOU COULD WORK ON
SOMETHING ALONG THOSE LINES.
THE LEGISLATION WE'VE SEEN
PROBABLY OF THE LAST FIVE OR SIX
YEARS HAS CERTAINLY MOVED IN
THAT DIRECTION AND I THINK THAT
AS LEGISLATORS LIKE YOURSELF
KEEP BRINGING THIS ISSUE UP IN
AND MISSED CENTER DOT BRINGS
THIS ISSUE OF I THINK WE'RE
MOVING CLOSER AND CLOSER TO THAT
FACT.
AND IDEALLY I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT
WE SHOULD HAVE A CENTRAL HUB OF
INFORMATION THE JUST TARGETS HOW
DO WE COMBAT HUNGER ON CAMPUS.
AND BRING ALL THOSE TOOLS IN --
I DON'T THE HEADING THAT
DIRECTION IF IT'S POSSIBLE WOULD
SEEM TO MAKE SENSE I I'M
ASSUMING HE WOULD HAVE.
DONE THAT IF IT WERE.
POSSIBLE AND IT MIGHT NOT BE BUT
IF THERE'S SOMETHING WE CAN DO
TO STREAMLINE THIS I MEAN.
IT JUST SEEMS SO CRAZY THAT
WE'VE GOT TO GO THROUGH SO MANY
HOOPS JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE FED.
HEY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
CENTERS ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS
A CHILD OF A MODEST INCOME
FAMILY AND GOING TO SCHOOL --
WE DON'T HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF
MONEY TO BUY FOOD AND YOU LEARN
TO ADAPT WAS BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTIES YOU KNOW YOU.
KRAFT MACARONI AND CHEESE ATOP
RAHMAN YOU GOT TO GET THE
CALORIES SOMEPLACE AND ONE THING
I KNOW IS THAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE
AN APPROPRIATE NUTRITION --
IS GONNA REFLECTING YOUR ABILITY.
TO TO STUDY --
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING TIS
FORWARD IN THE HOMOGENEOUS
EFFORTS WITH BARACK BUREAUCRATIC
FORMS TO MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE --
GET THE SERVICES THEY NEED A
CERTAIN IMPORTANCE.
COURSES VERY TROUBLING IS WE'VE.
ALL BEEN --
HEARING ABOUT.
SO MANY COLLEGE STUDENTS --
LIVING IN THE CARS YOU KNOW
BECAUSE THE HOMELESS.
AND THEY'RE ONLY --
ESCAPE IF YOU WILL FROM THE
POVERTY SITUATION THEY FIND
THEMSELVES IN IS.
TO GET AN EDUCATION WHICH
HOPEFULLY WILL ALLOW THEM TO GET
A JOB [inaudible]
SO.
ON A LOT OF OUR UC CAMPUSES WERE
RIGHT WENT --
CAL STATE EVEN ON A LOT OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THEY HAVE FOOD SERVICES THERE --
UCLA YOU KNOW YOU COULD LOWER
THE DORMS AND FOR A FEE YOU CAN
GO TO THE CAFETERIA AND SO.
ARE THESE STUDENTS THAT QUALIFY
FOR COVERAGE OF THE ABLE TO
REDEEM THAT BENEFIT FOR SOME OF
THE ORGANIZED FOOD SERVICES THAT
EXIST ON OUR UC CAMPUSES AND CAL
STATE CAMPUSES.
AND NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT YOU
KNOW TAKING THE BENEFIT GOING
OFF CAMPUS TO GET FOOD COME TO
GET A RIGHT THERE IS A ONE STOP
SHOP.
BUT THAT THAT'S A TRICKY
QUESTION --
SO FEDERAL REGULATION ULTIMATELY
DRIVES CAL FOR ASH IN IN
CALIFORNIANS A ONE OF THE
PRECLUSION FROM CAL FIRST WHICH
IS SORT OF SHOCKING IS THAT IF
YOU'RE ON A MEAL PLAN.
SO TYPICALLY A MEAL PLAN WILL
PRECLUDE YOU FROM CAL FOR US
WITH FEDERAL REGULATIONS SO TO
SOME EXTENT.
WITH THAT QUESTION THE ANSWER IS
NO -- TO TWO
OTHER EXTEND SO THERE ARE
CAMPUSES ON CAMPUS.
I DAVIS IS ONE OF THOSE CAMPUSES
WHICH IS PHENOMENAL SO I THE EBT
CARD IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW IS
BASICALLY A DEBIT CARD THAT YOU
CAN USE YOUR FOOD BEEN RIGHT
IT'S ON IT'S IT'S NICE IT'S
DISCREET IT'S EASY TO USE JUST
LIKE.
OUR STANDARD DEBIT CARD --
IN AGAIN IN THE BILL ANALYSIS
THERE IS A SECTION THE TALK
ABOUT UNITY ON CAMPUS WHICH IS
AN AMAZING THING I THINK THE
MORE THE CAMPUS IS EMBRACE EBT.
YOU CAN USE IT IN THEIR THEIR
IT'S ALMOST LIKE A CONVENIENCE
STORE ON CAMPUS OR THE CAFETERIA
THE OTHER SPOTS.
ARE THE EASIER THE ACCESS IS FOR
FOR STUDENTS TO USE THOSE
BENEFITS THEY'RE AGAIN THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE AREAS WERE OFTEN
TIMES THE THE FEDERAL REGULATION --
DOESN'T ALWAYS MAKE TONS OF
SENSE YEAH LOCALLY IT IN SO MANY
THINGS BUT BUT THERE ARE OPTIONS
THERE'S AND THERE'S SIDE RATS
AND I'M IS THERE CHANGING.
I THINK ANYTHING WE COULD DO TO
ENCOURAGE THE SPREAD OF AB T.
ACCEPTANCE WHEREVER IS A GREAT
THING BECAUSE THAT'S FOOD ACCESS
AT THE ABILITY OF OF PEOPLE TO
USE THEIR BENEFITS AND YOU KNOW
IF YOU'RE IN THE HEART OF DAVIS
UC DAVIS CAMPUS IT'S PRETTY HARD
TO GET.
ALL THE WAY TO THE NEAREST STORE
RESTAURANT ETCETERA ETCETERA AND
SO IF YOU'RE RUNNING BETWEEN
CLASSES YOU NEED LUNCH --
I DO THINK TO SOME EXTENT
CAMPUSES EMBRACING THAT'S A
REALLY GOOD THING AND THAT'S
STARTING TO HAPPEN BUT I I KNOW
WE CAN ALL --
ENCOURAGE CAMPUSES OUR
RESPECTIVE DISTRICTS TO KIND OF
FOLLOW SUIT AND EXPLORE AB T. ON
CAMPUS.
SO -- I'M
SURE THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS A MICRO MANAGE EVERY BE THE
BENEFIT.
OF COURSE THEY CAN DO SOME
ANALYSIS AND I FIND IT SHOCKING
AS WELL AS YOU DO THAT --
MEAL PLANS WOULD BE EXCLUDED
WHEN AS IT'S SO CONVENIENT IS
ACTING VERY COST EFFECTIVE FOR
THEM TO UTILIZE THAT --
DO YOU USE.
DO YOU SEE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REALLY --
ENFORCING THAT --
OR SHOULD BE --
THINK WE SHOULD URGE SOME OF OUR
FEDERAL LEGISLATORS THIS I MEAN
HUNGER IN SCHOOLS OF IS A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE REMEMBER GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR KIDS ARE
GETTING THE PROPER NUTRITION SO
THEY CAN.
GET THEIR CAREERS AND STUDY WITH --
ANOTHER FUEL IN THE BRAIN TO TO
ACCOMPLISH OUR GOALS SO --
I WANT TO BELABOR THIS BUDGET I
FIND IT VERY SHOCKING THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE BILL FANS AND I
COULD TAKE MY CONGRESS WAS GOING
TO HEAR ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S WRONG.
AND IT SHOULD BE FIXED AT THE AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL SO THAT WE CAN.
EMBRACE IT AT THE AT THE STATE
LEVEL FOR FOR THESE GREAT KIDS
THAT ARE JUST LOOKING.
FOR A BETTER LIFE FOR THEMSELVES
INTO AGAIN SENATOR DON.
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR BRAND IS
FOR CENTER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE PER SHEET THE
RECOMMENDATIONS BILLS I
INDICATED EARLIER WHAT WE'VE
ACCEPTED THOSE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU.
SO THERE WAS A MOTION TO MOVE
THE BILL ARE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED SENATE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RETIRED FBI HER TITLE AYE STONE
AYE STONE AYE BELL.
BELL AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE PAN
HI AND I WINNER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE [inaudible] SIX SIX
VOTES AT THE BILL IS OUT.
BUT MEDICARE AND MEMBERS.
THE NEXT AUTHOR WE HAVE A
SENATOR SKINNER.
YOU HAVE SENATOR SKINNER TO
PRESENT SB.
TWO THREE FOUR WELCOME TO
SENATOR SKINNER AND TO YOUR
WITNESSES WESSEL WITNESSES KEEP
THEIR TESTIMONY TO TWO TO THREE
MINUTES.
BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS --
MY BILL WHICH YOU'RE HEARING
RIGHT OUT SB.
TWO THIRTY FOUR BASICALLY
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT.
WE HAVE A SERIOUS.
SHORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE
UP AND DOWN THE STATE THE PRICES
OF CHILD CARE HAS GROWN SO
ASTRONOMICALLY.
AND LICENSED CHILDCARE CURRENTLY
IS ONLY AVAILABLE 423% OF THE
CHILDREN WITH WORKING PARENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
RECOGNIZES THAT FAMILY OPERATED
HOME DAYCARE --
IS A OFTEN A FAR MORE AFFORDABLE
OPTION.
THAN OTHER FORMS OF CHILDCARE.
END.
IN THIS ECONOMY COULD BE
EXPANDED.
SO WHAT IT SB TWO THIRTY FOUR
DOES IS.
AMEND OUR STATUTE SO THAT WE
WOULD TREAT THE PERMIT
REQUIREMENTS FOR SMALL AND LARGE
FAMILY CHILDCARE HOMES LARGE
BEING FOR NO MORE THAN FOURTEEN
CHILDREN.
THE SAME.
AND CLEAR FIGHT THAT CHILD CARE
OF THIS SORT WOULD BE ALLOWED IN
APARTMENTS OR CONDOMINIUMS.
AND TO HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES INFORM CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS OF THEIR RIGHTS
OR THAT ALREADY EXIST UNDER THE
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT.
AND SO WITH ME TO PRESENT.
OUR LAURIE FOR FURTHER SPEND
FELT FROM THE TRUCK YOU'RE
LAWCENTER AND TANYA MCMILLAN WHO
IS A CHILD CARE PROVIDER AND A
MEMBER OF SEIU LOCAL NINETY NINE
AND ALSO.
PART OF THE CHILD CARE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION.
SO -- GOOD
AFTERNOON --
AS A FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDER I
SHARE A HEARING AND EDUCATING
CHILDREN SO THAT THEY HAVE A
GREAT START IN LIFE.
I'M HERE TODAY TO TELL YOU ABOUT
SB TWO THREE FOUR AND WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT.
WHAT SHOULD BE A SIMPLE RIGHT AS
A FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDER TO
OPERATE A FAMILY CHILDCARE IN A
HOME THAT I RAN?
WITHOUT HASSLE OR DISCRIMINATION
OFTEN COMES WITH THE PROCESS OF
BEING THREATENING AND EXTREMELY
FRUSTRATING --
I LOST MY HOME DURING THE
ECONOMIC CRISIS AND AS A RESULT
OF THAT I HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO
GRANT.
US SINCE THEN I'VE HAD TO DEAL
WITH LANDLORDS WHO REQUIRE THREE
TIMES THE DEPOSIT --
JUST BECAUSE I CARE FOR CHILDREN
IN MY HOME DESPITE WE HAVE IN
HOME CARE LIABILITY INSURANCE
THAT WOULD PROTECT THEM FROM
LIABILITY.
I FOUND THAT RENTAL APPLICATIONS
WERE EITHER DENIED OR REVOKED
THE MINUTE I TOLD THEM.
IN THE MINUTE I TOLD POTENTIAL
LANDLORD THE I HAD A HOME BASED
FAMILY CHILDCARE.
I SAW FOR SALE FIND TO BE PLACED
ON A HOME THAT I WAS RANTING TO
FIND OUT LATER THAT THE OWNER
NEVER HAD ANY INTENTION ON
SELLING HE JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT I WOULD VACATE THE
PROPERTY.
IN THE EASIEST POSSIBLE WAY.
SO I HAD TO MOVE THREE TIMES
SINCE I LOST MY HOME AND WITH
EACH MOVE THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL
SET OF CHALLENGES THAT COME WITH
IT.
TRYING TO FIND A HOME THAT'S
STILL IN MY NAME IT WILL
CONTINUE TO TO ACCESS THE
SERVICES.
THAT I PROVIDE FIRE INSPECTIONS
THAT NEED TO BE COMPLETED
LICENSING --
HAVING TO COME TO MY HOME AND
AND DEMI'S SAFE.
THERE'S A GAP IN CARE WHICH
MEANS A LOSS IN WAGES FOR ME AND
A LOSS AND CARE FOR THE FAMILIES
BECAUSE I CAN'T READ OPEN MY NEW
CHILD CARE UNTIL THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT --
LIES AND COMES IN AND SAYS IT'S
OKAY AND IT MEANS INSTABILITY
FOR OUR CHILDREN BECAUSE THEIR
PARENTS HAVE TO GO OUT AND FIND
TEMPORARY CARE UNTIL I CAN GET
BACK UP AND RUNNING.
SEOUL WHILE RENTING IS ALREADY A
DAUNTING TASK FOR MANY OF US AS
WE FIND SKYROCKETING RENTS ON
AFFORDABLE. FOR FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS IT CREATES A
WHOLE EXTRA LEVEL OF ANXIETY.
MY ABILITY TO RUN MY BUSINESS
EARN A LIVING AND PROVIDE
FAMILIES WITH THE NEEDED CARE
INTRICATELY TIED TO WHERE I LIVE
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB
[inaudible]
TWO THREE FOUR GOOD AFTERNOON.
EVERY BABY DESERVES TO GROW UP
IN A WARM AND LOVING ENVIRONMENT
AND EVERY PARENT DESERVES TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE FAMILY CHILD CARE
CLOSE TO HOME.
THAT PUTS THEIR MIND AT EASE
WHILE THEY WORK MY NAME IS
LAURIE FURSTENFELD AND I'M A
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
CHILD CARE LAWCENTER.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER FOR
AUTHORING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL THAT WILL BRING MUCH RELIEF
TO FAMILIES IN SEARCH OF CHILD
CARE.
THE CHILD CARE LAWCENTER WE HEAR
EVERY WEEK ESPECIALLY WHEN
CITIES OR COUNTIES BLOCK
PROVIDERS FROM GETTING THEIR
ZONING PERMITS THE PARENTS ARE
FORCED TO QUIT THEIR JOBS.
CUT BACK THEIR HOURS --
COBBLED TOGETHER ON RELIABLE
SITUATIONS THAT LACK THE LIVING
HOME ENVIRONMENT THAT THEY WANT
FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE
FAMILY CHILD CARE CLOSE TO HOME
IS AVAILABLE.
IT WILL UPDATE PROTECTIONS FOR
FAMILY CHILD CARE PAST NEARLY
FORTY YEARS AGO TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF TODAY'S FAMILIES.
I'M SENATOR SKINNER ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT THE MEAN TENANTS OF
THE BILL I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
THE ONE TENANT THAT REDUCES RED
TAPE BY REQUIRING THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STREET LICENSED
FAMILY CHILD CARE AT LARGE
LICENSED FAMILY CHILD CARE IT'S
A RESIDENTIAL USE A PROPERTY.
THE SAME A SMALL HOMES THERE'S
QUITE A NUMBER OF CITIES AND
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
THAT ALREADY DO THIS IF YOU'D
LIKE THAT LIST I CAN PROVIDE
THAT TO YOU --
A FEW OF THESE PLACES INCLUDE AT
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO.
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO DAVIS THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO VALLEJO.
WE JUST WANT EQUAL LIES IN
STREAMLINED THESE REQUIREMENTS
STATEWIDE.
THIS BILL DOES NOT.
CHANGE ANY OF THE LICENSING FIRE
AND SAFETY REQUIREMENTS OF THOSE
ALL REMAIN THE SAME.
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE BILL'S LANGUAGE I'M HAPPY TO
OFFER ANY TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THERE'S ALSO A NUMBER OF FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS HERE.
WHO ARE CURRENTLY UNDERGOING
SOME I'M DIFFICULTY AND BARRIERS
WHO -- PER
HAVING PROBLEMS GETTING THERE IS
OWNING PERMITS IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THEM [inaudible]
FAST.
TOO AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
IF SO PLEASE COME UP TO THE
STUDY MICROPHONE AND STATE YOUR
NAME.
WHAT ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT
IF ANY AND YOUR POSITION OF
SUPPORT?
MY NAME IS PAUL WITH SNOW SKI
THIS IS MY WIFE JACQUELINE WAS
THE SPECIES THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDER FOR OUR FACILITY THAT
WE CO OWNED.
IT SOARING WINGS NAPA CHILD CARE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT SB --
TWO THREE FOUR PETER FINANCIAL
LIMITATIONS IN AN EFFORT TO KEEP
INFANT TODDLERS AND A HIGH
QUALITY HOME SETTING.
HE SUPPORT THE BILL [inaudible]
IF YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JACKIE
LONG I'M WITH GRACE AND I MANAGE
THEN CHILD POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA
CAMPAIGN WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THIS BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN
SUPPORTING COMMUNITIES.
AND THE DOCTOR NEEDS THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS BEING --
CHARBROIL I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE FUTURE SUPPORTING FAMILY
TARGET OF CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
THAT WE SAID WE BOUGHT EIGHT
HUNDRED PROVIDERS.
AND I'M ALSO IN MENTOR TEACHER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE --
MENTOR TEACHER PROGRAM I'M A
LARGE FAMILY TARGET PROVIDERS
SERVING MY COMMUNITY FOR ABOUT
NINETEEN YEARS.
I I'M HERE TO REQUEST YOUR WARD
ON YES I WOULD ON AS BE TWO
THREE FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HI ALL MY NAME IS CHARLOTTE
WILLIAMS I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDCARE RESOURCE AND REFERRAL
NETWORK.
OUT WE ARE CO SPONSORING THIS
BILL WITH THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER AND SEIU.
AND WE FULLY SUPPORT THE BILL --
WE KNOW THAT AND HAVE ACTUALLY
FOUND THAT --
DUE TO THE RECESSION OF 30% OF
THE HOMES THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
AVAILABLE FOR CHILDCARE ARE NOW
NO LONGER AVAILABLE AND I WOULD
IMAGINE MANY OF THOSE REASONS
ARE WHAT --
HE DISCUSSED EARLIER WE ALSO
KNOW THAT MANY OF OUR FAMILIES
RELY ON FAMILY CHILDCARE HOMES
AND NONTRADITIONAL SETTINGS AS
WELL THAT THE LAST MINUTE AND I
ALSO PERSONALLY KNOW THAT AS A
MOM OF TWO AND SO WE HOPE THAT
YOU ALL WILL VOTE YES ON THIS.
MUCH NEEDED BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SALLY SETTLEMENT
I'M A LARGE --
LICENSED CHILDCARE PROVIDER IN
PART OF SONGS THAN HIS LAOS.
IN I JUST WANNA MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT ABOUT --
MY EX HUSBAND --
FOR SPELLING PATTERSON JUST
RECENTLY GOT THE SMALL LICENSE.
A PART OF Sí
RENTING A HOUSE THINK HE DID PAY.
THE DOUBLE THE POST IT IN THE
FIRST MONTH OF FRONT OF COURSE
BUT IT BECAME LIKE SEVEN
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS.
YES TO BE ABLE TO OPEN HALF
EXPERT INSURANCE AS A RENTAL IN
OUR FAMILY CHILD CARE --
INSURANCE TOO SO YES I DO
SUPPORT SB.
TWO THREE FOUR AFTER NAY MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF REALLY ON
BEHALF FOR YOU TO THE ASK ME
LOCAL THREE NINE THIRTY AS A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL WE ARE YOUR
SUPPORT AS WELL AS TO PROVIDE
SECURITY TO LARGE FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOMES.
AND WHAT'S VERY IMPORTANT IS
THAT THESE PROVIDERS ARE HERE TO
OFFER A WARM STATE OR TRAM
PHARMACY CHILDREN AND THIS WILL
HELP THEM OUT THANK YOU.
I AM A VETERAN OF LOCAL PROVIDE
THE VALVE SMALL THE CURVE AND
THE MOM BUT FOR A PROVIDE
SERVICE.
ASSOCIATION OF FAMILY DAY CARE.
AND THE I APPLIED FOR THE
LUGGAGE THEY COULD HAVE TO
EXPAND.
OUR AND WAS DENIED OF WAS THE
VOLATILE CREEK CT.
WAS OVER THERE.
ON FURTHER AND THE ON THE
REASONABLE LAWS AND I COULD HAVE
WOULD RELEASED THE WAITING LIST
AND THE HEAVENS CALLED ME OVER
THE THEY ARE TO HAVE A SPOT.
IN THE EYES OF A FUSE THEM
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE A SENIOR NO
WAY OUT OF A SPOT FOR THE EVEN
FUND WHAT THEY SHOULD DO I NEED
TO GO TO WORK. FOR I WILL NOT
BEEN GET TOP TWO YOU'LL.
EXTEND THE RESPECTFULLY ASK TO
VOTE FOR THE ARE SB IT TO THE
FOURTH.
MIKE WE GOT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION LIKE DILEMMA
COMES THOSE OF YOU W. A. C. R.
U. S. ROSSPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DRESS YOUR ANGLE
I LIVE IN PLACE AND TONE I HAVE
A LARGE FAMILY TAKER I'VE BEEN
LICENSED BY THE STATE.
PERCENT AMMAN'S --
I STARTED THE PROCESS IN
NOVEMBER.
AND FIRE CLEARANCES STANDS STATE
LICENSING HIS LAN.
CITY WAS APPROVED.
THE APPEAL PROCESS AND MOST
LIKELY WOULD GO TO THEIR NEXT
ONE AS WELL.
OPERATIVE TONY'S VERY WHAT THE
COMMUNITY IS RELUCTANT TO CHANGE.
AND SO I'M SOMEONE WHO IS
FIGHTING THE SYSTEM BUT NOT
EVERYONE HAS --
THE MEANS TO DO SO OR DAY --
THE GUY.
BECAUSE HE'S NOT EASY TO STAND
HERE IN FRONT OF YOU SO --
I LOOK FORWARD.
TO A MAKING MY NEIGHBORS
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY REALLY HAVE
NO SAME BECAUSE THIS THUNDER
SUMMER.
BUT THE PROCESS IS GOING TO TAKE
AT LEAST SIX TO EIGHT MONTHS AND
I AM FINANCIALLY STRUGGLING AS
WELL AS MY PARENTS --
THERE ARE LIKE WHEN ARE YOU
GOING OFF AND YOU'RE READY ARE
YOU READY WE NEED WE NEED CHILD
KERR.
SO -- ALSO I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
FAMILIES ACRES.
THERE ARE A TOTAL DIFFERENT
SETTING THAN HEALTHCARE CENTERS
IN A CENTER.
YOU HAVE A WHOLE.
INSTITUTE BAKER ARE.
IS A DIFFERENT SENSE OF A
DIFFERENT FEELING.
AND THAT'S WHY I OPENED A FAMILY
BAKER BECAUSE I COULD NOT GIVE
MY CHILD ONTO A CENTER.
I WANTED THAT FAMILIES THIRTY IF
YOU -- THREE
TWELVE FOURTEEN FOURTEEN
STUDENTS.
IT'S MORE FAMILY BAKER SIDE
LICENSE FOR EIGHT STUDENTS LARGE
FAMILY BAKER A LICENSE FOR
FOURTEEN BY TWELVE PHOTOS
FORTIES.
CAN BE PRE SCHOOL AGE AND
YOUNGER THE OTHER TO HAVE TO BE
SCHOOL AGE SO REALLY THE CHANGE
HERE IS NOT IS FORCED FOR MORE
STUDENTS THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
BECAUSE THE ORDER TO STUDENTS
WOULD CALM.
AFTER THREE THREE THIRTY SO ON
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO THE
BILL AND FOR HIS POSSIBLE FOR
YOUR PLEASE MAKE IT POSSIBLE
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE ARE.
THE NEED TO THIS REPORT OF THE
LAW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON I'M SUCH A HARD TIME
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MCKENZIE CHRISTIANSEN AND I AM
WITH THAT CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM OR CAP BUT AND
WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS NANCY WHY IT ON
THE BOARD MMBER AND THE PUBLIC
POLICY CHAIR FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILY CHILD CARE NETWORK IN A
PROVIDER. FOR THIRTY THREE YEARS
PLEASE VOTE I ON SB.
TWO THIRTY FOUR HI GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS JESSICA MAGDALENO I
MY FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDER IN
THE CITY OF ORANGE COUNTY.
I HAVE A LARGE LICENSE FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS.
AND I'M WITH THE HISPANIC ARE
RICHER BOARD MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILY CHILDCARE NO
NETWORK.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT.
B. L. AS BE.
TWO THIRTY FOUR AM AS IN MANY
OTHER PROVIDERS I WANNA SHARE TO
YOU WITH YOU THAT MY SISTER.
HAS BEEN AFFECTED BY THE
PROPERTY OWNERS MATT BEING
FLEXIBLE AND DECLINE HER
APPLICATION SEVERAL TIMES WHICH
HOUSE HER.
HOUSE HER HER KIDS AND HER
FAMILY'S SERVER MANY PROBLEMS.
STILL OUR E. B. HAVE ALL OF
THESE PROVIDERS I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S OSCAR OFF AND
FROM SAN FRANCISCO --
I'M APPALLED MEMBER ON DEAF AND
THE CHILD CARE ASSOCIATION OF
SEVENTIES CALL AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY CHILD CARE
NETWORK -- I
HAVE WE IN AN APARTMENT AND THEN
WE DO EXPERIENCE ON THE H. O. A
TO TRY TO IMPOSE SOME --
YEAH RESTRICTION ON US TILL I
LUCKILY WE HAVE THEIR SUPPORT
FROM DUTCH OKAY LAWCENTER AND
AND ALL SOUL --
WAY NO WE ARE --
YEAH WE MOVE UP BECAUSE OF YEAH
WE WE WE WANT TO EXPAND TO A
LARGE LICENSE --
BUT WE ARE EXPERIENCING A
TOLERANCE WITH --
STATE I MEAN THERE ARE FIRE
MARSHAL CHALLENGE ALREADY BUT I
CANNOT IMAGINE --
YEAH OTHER POLL WHY THERE'S THEY
HAVE FOG WITHOUT ONE MORE TO
LICENSING BECAUSE SUMMER THIS
CALL WE DON'T.
NEED THAT ZONING PERMIT --
YEAH BUT I A ARE SOME THE FULL.
MY NAME IS TONY ROBERTSON.
AND I STARTED THIRTY YEARS AGO
AS A FAMILY CHILDCARE PREVENT
PROVIDER.
TODAY I WORK AT THE COCOA KIDS
THE RESOURCE REFERRAL AGENCY IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THAT I WORK
WITH PROVIDERS FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS.
HELPING THEM WITH THEIR
BUSINESSES AND THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE THAT WE FACE ARE USE
PERMITS.
BECAUSE EVERY CITY IT'S
DIFFERENT AND SOME PROVIDERS ARE
ABLE TO EXPAND THEIR BUSINESSES
AND OTHERS ART.
WE ARE AT A DEVASTATING MOMENT
IN TIME BECAUSE CHILD CARE IS SO.
SCARCE.
AND THIS IS PUTTING SOME OF OUR
PROVIDERS OUT OF BUSINESS.
WE CAN'T HAVE ANYMORE PROVIDERS
LEAVE THIS FIELD.
THERE'S A SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA
AND AND ESPECIALLY IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY --
I'M ASKING RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR
HIGH NOW I VOTE.
HI MY NAME IS GINA JACKSON
WARNING AND I AM A FOUNDER OF
THE FUTURE SUPPORTING FAMILY
CHILD CARE OF LET'S COUNT OF
COUPLE COUNTY --
MY DAYCARE IS SMALL AND WEST
COUNTY.
AND I AM ENCOURAGING YOU.
TO HI MY NAME IS GLORIOUS
JACKSON OF IN THE FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDER FOR THIRTY
FOUR YEARS NOW.
AND I'M ONE OF THE FOUNDERS OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILY CHILDCARE
NETWORK AND ALSO FUTURE
SUPPORTING FAMILY CHILDCARE AND
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION. TO THIS
BILL. THREE NINE WILL MOVE
FORWARD ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR THE AUTHOR AND SB.
TWO THREE FOUR AND CENTERS ON
THANK YOU UP.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
SKINNER THANK YOU.
FOR HI KAREN THIS LEGISLATION.
OF THE STATISTICS --
OR STARTLING 67% --
HAVE TROUBLE AFFORDING FINING --
DAYCARE CENTER --
IN IN IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS --
HALL ALSO WANT TO THANK YOUR
MIND A CATCH YOUR NAME BUT I WAS
VERY SADDENED ABOUT YOUR STORY.
LOSS OF YOUR HOME AND AND THAT
THE TRIALS AND TRIBULATIONS THAT
YOU HAD TO INDOOR GOING FROM
RESIDENTS TO RESIDENTS.
TO BASICALLY PROVIDE THE ANGELIC
CARE THAT.
MANY HER COLLEAGUES THAT ARE
HERE TODAY PROVIDE ARE.
ARE WONDERFUL KIDS SO --
I WOULD I WAS JUST WONDERING
SENATOR SKINNER --
IN WE DID HEAR THE WORD CC AND
ARE NOT WAS GOING TO ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS HOW WOULD THIS AFFECT --
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE.
COVENANT RESTRICTIONS --
CONDITION COVEN RESTRICTIONS AND
OR IF THEY'RE IN FIFTY FIVE OR
OLDER COMMUNITIES.
ELDER ELDERLY PEOPLE THAT ARE
LOOKING.
FOR THINGS TO DO THAT ARE
SATISFIED WITH YOUR MORE
SATISFYING THAN TAKING CARE OF
YOUNG KIDS.
WITH THIS LOS SUPERSEDE --
WHAT IS WRITTEN IN THOSE
AGREEMENTS OR WITH THOSE STILL
PREAMP THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
LAW?
CRAZY MYERS.
ACTUALLY THAT THE H. AWAY --
RESTRICTIONS THAT'S ALREADY
SETTLED AREA OF LIFE THE STATE
LAW OR HE SAYS THAT FAMILY CHILD
CARE -- MUST
BE CONSIDERED A RED FOR LEASE
AGREEMENTS ARE EACH CCN OURS.
AND THERE CAN BE NO PROHIBITIONS
ABOUT ALLOWING FAMILY CHILD CARE
IN -- H.
OASIS.
IN AND I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO
THE REMEDY IS A LITTLE BIT BUT
CAN YOU COULD EXPLAIN IT TO A
LAY PERSON.
THE REMEDIES --
EIGHT PERSON COULD USE OF THE H.
AWAY GIVE SOME.
TROUBLE AND AND THEN AGAIN THIS
IS AFFECT THE FIFTY FIVE AN
OLDER COMMUNITIES THE SAME WAY
THAT IT DOES THE C. C. R. I
DON'T KNOW AND TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT THE FIFTY FIVE AN
OLDER AND THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION
AND I HAVE TO GET BACK TO ABOUT.
THAT SPECIFIC QUESTION MIGHT BE
SOMETHING THAT.
THROUGH THE PROGRESS OF THIS
BILL THAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO
ENTERTAIN BECAUSE I THINK.
IT COULD BE A A PLACE WHERE.
WE WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
THE SENIOR CITIZENS THAT ARE
LOOKING TO TAKE CARE OF OUR KIDS
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO
WITHOUT.
DURING THE BIG BROTHERS LOOKING
OVER THEIR SHOULDER TO MAKE LIFE
MISERABLE FOR THEM SO --
THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS OF THANKS AGAIN FOR
PRESERVING THE BILL.
ABOVE IT WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE.
SENATE JACKSON THANK YOU --
JUST A QUICK QUESTION THE IS
THIS --
LEGISLATION DESIGNED TO EXPAND
THE ABILITY OF FAMILY DAY CARE
HOMES IN APARTMENT COMPLEXES --
AND THE IS THAT ACCURATE THAT IT
WILL.
SO IF SOMEONE WANTS TO OPEN A
FACILITY IN AN APARTMENT COMPLEX
THEY WILL NOW BE ABLE TO DO SO
WHERE IS BEFORE THEY WERE NOT.
WELL IT DEPENDS ON THE
JURISDICTION THERE MANY
JURISDICTIONS FOR WHICH WAS
ALLOWED WAS ONE OF THOSE THE
STATE LAW IS NOT CLEAR SO THERE
WAS NO BLANKET.
OF ELIMINATION NO BLANKET
PROHIBITION ON APARTMENTS OR
CONDOS FOR THAT MATTER BUT THERE
WERE IT WAS IRREGULARLY APPLIED
AND SOME JURORS SO YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR UNIFORMITY CORRECT.
SO IF I MAY JUST ASK THIS
QUESTION AND CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT WE'VE GOT TO HAVE MORE.
CHILD CARE IN ALL DIFFERENT
LEVELS AND IF YOU'RE.
WILLING TO PUT UP WITH FOURTEEN
LITTLE ONES GOD BLESS YOU --
IT ONE SPACE BUT I WONDER IN
APARTMENT COMPLEXES I I'M I'M
JUST THINKING OF THE OTHER
PEOPLE IN AN APARTMENT COMPLEX
WE WANT THESE KIDS HAVE A GREAT
TIME WE WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO
PLAY OUTSIDE RECREATION BE
CHILDREN --
BUT I DO KNOW A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO WORK SORT OF NONTRADITIONAL
HOURS.
AND SO IF THEY'RE TRYING TO
SLEEP IT DURING THE DAY WHEN
WE'VE GOT A CHILD CARE.
OF FACILITY THERE DO THEY IF YOU
KNOW HOW DO WE ADDRESS THERE
RIGHT TO THE QUITE ENJOYMENT OF
THEIR OF THEIR APARTMENT FORCES
YOU KNOW HAVING A ROBUST AREA
FREEDOM LITTLE WANTS TO TO BE
CHILDREN.
SO THIS BILL DOES NOT MODIFY
WHATSOEVER ANY STANDARDS AROUND.
THE THERE'S A CORE OF
ALLOCATIONS OF SPACE
REQUIREMENTS PER CHILD THERE'S
VARIOUS REQUIREMENTS SO THIS
BILL DOES NOT ALTER THAT.
THOSE ARE STILL IN THE CODE SO
YOU KNOW LET'S SAY YOU HAD.
I'M JUST BEING HYPOTHETICAL HERE
A THREE HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT
APARTMENT OR SOMETHING.
NOT.
YOU WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE A
FOURTEEN EVEN IFWE PASS THIS
LAW SO SO THOSE THINGS IT DOES
NOT OVERRIDE THE LICENSE
REQUIREMENTS ARE STILL --
STILL EXIST.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT THE
ABILITY YOUR HOURS OF YOUR
FACILITY ARE ALSO --
YOU HAVE TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE
IN IN GETTING YOUR PERMIT AND WE
DO NOT CHANGE ANYTHING AROUND
REQUIRING SAY THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NO DON'T GET TO HAVE
A SAY OVER.
THE HOURS OF YOUR PERMITTED --
WHEN YOU HAVE THE --
FACILITY OPEN RIGHT SO CERTAINLY
IN THOSE CASES WHERE --
THE THE APARTMENT COMPLEXES SUCH
WHERE YOU WHERE YOU WOULD NOT BE
ABLE -- TO
PROTECT ANY OF YOUR RESIDENT OF
THE RESIDENTS FROM.
POTENTIAL DISRUPTION YOU KNOW
THAT WOULD BE FACTORED I IMAGINE
BY THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
ADDITIONALLY --
WELL I A STATED THAT THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW FOR THE FOURTEEN
THAT THE CHILD CARE FACILITIES
WITH FOURTEEN CHILDREN TO BE
TREATED THE SAME AS EIGHT ARE
ONE OF OUR SPEAKERS DID MAKE A
CORRECTION WHICH IS ACCURATE.
WHICH I DID NOT --
GIVE THOUGH IT THAT DETAIL WHICH
IS REALLY IT'S ALLOWING FOR FOR
MORE CHILDREN.
IT IS SO GOES TO TWELVE THE TWO
ADDITIONAL UNDER THE EXISTING
LAW WHICH WE DON'T CHANGE WOULD
HAVE TO BE AFTER SCHOOL SO THEY
WOULD NOT BE A FULL DAY.
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE AND
THEN IF THERE'S ANY OTHER LEGAL
POINT THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE YES
I ALSO WANTED TO ADD THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL HAVE
BOTH ISSUED GUIDANCE --
IT'S NOT IT'S BEEN IN STANDING
FOR MANY YEARS THAT FAMILY CHILD
CARE IS ALLOWED IN APARTMENTS
AND CONDOS WE'RE CLEANING UP THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL TO CLARIFY
AND I AND LAKE --
SENATOR SKINNER SAID --
THE FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
WHAT'S THE REQUIREMENTS WITHIN
APARTMENTS AND CONDOS IN THE
BOTTOM LINE IS ALSO THAT THERE'S
MANY FAMILIES WHO LIVE IN
APARTMENTS WHO ALSO NEED
CHILDCARE CLOSE TO HOME.
AND SO WE HAVE SIT CITIES THAT
WE KNOW OF WHERE THEY BANNED
FAMILY CHILD CARE FROM
APARTMENTS FAMILIES WHO ARE
LIVING IN APARTMENTS ARMENIANS
DRIVE TO THE NEXT TOWN. TO GET
CHILD CARE.
IT UP I UNDERSTAND THE SAID.
IT'S A BIT OF A WEIGHING PROCESS
BECAUSE OF LET'S SAY I MANAGE
YOUR OWN AN EIGHT UNIT APARTMENT
BUILDING ND I KNOW THAT TWO OF
THE PEOPLE IN MY UNITS ARE LET'S
SEE NURSES.
AND THEY WORK FROM ELEVEN PM TO
SEVEN AM OR EIGHT AM --
AND THEY WANT TO COME HOME AND
SLEEP ED IN THE SYSTEM THAT I'M
CALM THE SITUATION --
ARE YOU INDICATING THAT THAT
WE'VE ALREADY MADE A POLICY
DECISION THAT SAYS.
THAT IF THERE'S A FAMILY DAYCARE
CENTER IT CAN STILL OPERATE
WITHIN THAT APARTMENT UNIT IN
THE PEOPLE WHO WORKED IN ON
TRADITIONAL HOURS ARE JUST GOING
TO HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT OR MOVE.
AT A GET OFF.
I'VE NEVER HAD THE GOOD THE
MISFORTUNE I SHOULD SAY OF
HAVING TO WORK THOSE HOURS BUT I
KNOW THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO DO AND
I JUST WONDER WHAT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE OF THE
PROPERTY MANAGER OR THE THE
PROPERTY OWNER --
IN LAW TODAY BECAUSE IF WE'RE
EXPANDING IT I JUST LIKE TO BE
AWARE OF THAT OR WE JUST SIMPLY.
CONFIRMING EXISTING OR EXPANDING
EXISTING LAW ONLY TO THE EXTENT
WERE INCREASING THE NUMBER
CHILDREN IT'S REALLY DAY.
THE AS WAS POINTED OUT IT'S
REALLY MAKING A AND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HAS ALREADY MADE THE CLARITY
THAT.
THERE YOU YOU TECHNICALLY ARE
ALLOWED TO HAVE THESE FAMILY
CHILDCARE FACILITIES IN
APARTMENTS.
IT'S JUST THAT THEIR BY NOT
HAVING IT REALLY IN STATUTE IT
CAN BE --
SOME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
CHOOSE TO ENTER PRODUCES CERTAIN
WAY.
WHAT ABOUT THE PROPERTY OWNERS
MY ONLY QUESTION SO IT CAN TAKE
THAT PERSON ONCE IN A UNIT?
OF THE PARTIAL AND THEY'VE GOT
TENANTS WHO ARE ALREADY IN THERE.
WHO ARE NONTRADITIONAL WORKERS
AND -- YOU
CREATE A CHILD CARE PROGRAM AND
THE PEOPLE COME TO YOU AND SAY
LOOK I WAS HERE FIRST I CAN'T
SLEEP IT'S TOO NOISY WE GOT A
BUNCH OF THE KIDS HERE NOW AND
WILD THEY LOVE KIDS OR WHATEVER.
THAT YOU KNOW WHO WHO'S.
WHOSE GOD WHOSE OX GETS CORD
HERE OR NOT.
WELL I WILL SAY THAT THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS THAT APPLY TO EVERY
OTHER RESIDENT APPLIED TO FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS --
AND UNDER CURRENT LAW.
PROPERTY MANAGERS CANNOT
PROHIBIT.
THEY USE OF THE OPERATION OF
FAMILY CHILD CARE AND FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS.
ALL THE ONES THAT WE WORK WITH
REALLY WORK WITH THEIR NEIGHBORS
TO ACCOMMODATE THEIR NEEDS IF
THEY KNOW THAT THEIR SOMEBODY
HOME THAT SLEEPING BILL STEIGER
KIDS HOME YOU KNOW STAGGER
ACTIVITIES MORE QUIET ACTIVITIES
DURING THE TIMES THAT PEOPLE
SLEEP.
OR YOU KNOW --
OUTSIDE SO FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND TINY CAN SPEAK
MORE TO THIS --
THEY REALLY DO YOU WORK A LOT
WITH THEIR NEIGHBORS TIM.
CREATE A PEACEFUL LEAVING LIVING
ENVIRONMENT.
YEAH AND THEN WE SHARE SOMETHING
TOO BECAUSE I KNOW AUTOMATICALLY
PEOPLE WHEN WHEN WE SAY.
CHILD CARE ENVIRONMENT YOU
AUTOMATICALLY THINK OF CRYING
BABIES.
I WAS THINKING OF LAUGHING KIDS
OVER. NINE SO BUT THE SAME WAY
THAT THERE IS A CERTAIN.
LICENSING MANDATES THAT THERE'S
A CERTAIN NUMBER OF SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN.
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN THEY
MANDATE HOW MANY EVENTS WITH TO
HAVE ALSO AND I THINK EVERYBODY
WHO BECAUSE I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
TWENTY FOUR YEARS.
I WHEN I DECIDED TO DO THIS I
WAS VERY CONSCIENTIOUS ABOUT.
WHAT I WAS ABOUT TO DO AND I
WHEN I STARTED BEFORE I BOUGHT
MY HOME I DID LIVE IN A TOWN
HOUSE?
AND I HAVE.
OF MY NEIGHBORS.
THEY HAD CHILDREN.
TO AND SO I REALIZED THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT I WAS GETTING
READY TO START THIS BUSINESS AND
THEN I ALSO REALIZE THAT THERE
WOULD BE A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
NOISE.
THAT WHEN I MOVED INTO THAT
TOWNHOUSE THERE WERE --
IN MY LEASE.
THERE WERE RULES THERE AND SO I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTOOD THAT AND
SO.
WE HAVE THE SAME RULES AS ANY
OTHER TENANT [inaudible]
BUT I STRONGLY BELIEVE.
AND I STAND BY THE FACT THAT
BEFORE WE START DOING THIS
BUSINESS WE'RE VERY VERY MUCH
AWARE OF WHAT WE'RE GETTING
READY TO DO AND WHAT THIS
BUSINESS.
BRINGS WITH IT AND I THINK I IN
ALL MY YEARS ON ONLY KNOWN ONE
HONESTLY ONE PROVIDER.
WHO'S EVER HAD ANY KIND OF
DISAGREEMENT OR COMPLAINTS.
FROM HER NEIGHBORS BECAUSE OF
CHILDREN SO.
I'MON WELL I BELIEVE THAT THIS
MAY SEEM LIKE A FUNNY ANECDOTE
TO USE BUT YOU KNOW WE NUMBER
ONE IN.
HOUSING POLICY WE DO NOT ALLOW
FOR DISCRIMINATION AROUND AT THE
RENTAL TO FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN
AND WE DON'T PUT ANY LIMIT ON
HOW MANY CHILDREN YOU MAY HAVE.
AND IF YOU COULD --
MAY ALL MY NEIGHBORS SINCE I
GREW UP IN A HOUSEHOLD WITH --
EIGHT BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
AND WE WERE NOT QUIET.
AND WE HAD A NEIGHBOR WHO WAS A
PROFESSIONAL MUSICIAN HE WAS A
DRUMMER HE PRACTICED IN THE DAY.
SO AND WE ARE ANOTHER NEIGHBOR
WHO WAS --
YOU LIKE TO WELD AND I MEAN
ANYWAY WE HAD A LOT OF NEIGHBORS
THAT DID LOUD STUFF.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER WE WERE
WORSE OR THEY WERE.
BUT THEY OFF.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT JUST
I WANT TO ANTICIPATE WHAT MIGHT
BE.
OF CONCERN AND CERTAINLY AGAIN I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND
I HOPE THOSE KIDS ALL LAUGHING
AND NOT COMING.
CENTERS SCANNERS TODAY WE HAD.
TEN YEAH I DON'T KNOW KNOWS NINE
TOTAL I SAID EIGHT BROTHERS AND
SISTERS I HAD I I HAVE NINE
BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
OKAY.
OKAY SO --
SO WE HAD TWELVE AND YEAH I KNOW
I I HAVE TO SAY THAT YOU PRICE
WHILE WE GOT IN TROUBLE BUT BUT
WE WORKED OUT THE THE PROBLEMS
AND LAND USE ISSUES.
YOU WANT TO BE HONEST ABOUT IT.
A GOOD CHILD --
GOOD OPERATOR FAMILY DAYCARE
WILL OPERATE IN A GOOD WAY
THOUGH WITH OUR NEIGHBORS.
LET'S SAY IT'S NOT A LAND USE
ISSUE AS MUCH.
IT'S MORE OF A MANAGEMENT ISSUE.
THAT'S MY PLAN MY MOTHER AND DAD.
WE'RE PRETTY GOOD MANAGERS.
I WILL I WILL COMMON.
YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
NOW OKAY.
S..
CENTER SKINNER PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU CARE AND THANK YOU --
COLLEAGUES FOR REALLY --
ROBUST DISCUSSION ON THE BILL
AND I HOPE YOUR QUESTIONS HAVE
BEEN ANSWERED AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER --
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
MADONNA I RETIRED AYE STONE.
STONE AYE BELL.
BELL AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN HI CAN I WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
SIX THE BILL IS.
SIX THE BILL IS OUT.
SO THIS CONCLUDES THIS HEARING
FOR THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
MEETING ADJOURNED